[Music]  the unlv athletic department finding  itself with another transition of power  the school's president appointed an  interim a.d john treach is here in  studio with more now on the man in  charge hey john hey there brian after  four years in the desert desiree reid  francois made the move to mizzou now  unlv is searching for their third  athletic director in five years  president keith whitfield has pinned a  promotion on a familiar face and a  stabilizing force eric harper is the  interim athletics director for the  university of nevada las vegas the  school president said he'll serve the  role as they conduct a national search  harper has been unlv's senior associate  a.d in charge of development for the  past nine years he's been a university  administrator for three decades and  played college football at kansas state  harbor fills the void left by desiree  reid francois who accepted the athletic  director position at mizzou five days  ago